Imamo pravna pravila koja su ona pravila
koja imaju uređenu funkcionisane države
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisane države
koja su podlana čelo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija je odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti koju imamo državno
dajem na različitom stepenu vlasti.
A kod koordinacije
imamo isti stepen vlasti
i imamo sarari.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se, jel da, zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Dakle, kada je reč o ljudima,
premaćemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade, kako rade i kakav je njihov
odnos prema državi kao organizaciju.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svostavni liško.
Znači taj državni aparat čine
samo neke ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenim licima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u imenu za računom državu.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određene poslove.
Dakle,
imate potređenu državnu službenu lice,
date mu da rade neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu radu.
Ja se obudim
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim,
ne da se držim ti definicije službenika,
nego najprostije moguće da vam objasnim.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao, daš ga jednom
državnom tvornom ulicu i kažeš evo ti,
napravo radi to,
to je tvoja nadležnost, bukvalno tako.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i ova treća nekako funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno
u radu državnih ordana,
Ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudija
koji je državno službeno lice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državno službeno lice,
da li oni rade isti?